the white hole is a proper journeyman
and has been roaming space for millions
of years kicking butt and taking names
that's because scientists theorize that
this white hole used to be a black hole
scientists suspect that after millions
of years black holes will become white
holes
and all the energy and matter they
consumed over the years will be expelled
back into space
[Music]
said when a black hole becomes a white
hole might not last very long so it will
need to act quickly if it wants to pick
a fight with a black hole
and despite it being different the white
hole is just as destructive as a black
hole if not more so
the matter the white hole is ejecting
moves at the speed of light